les services sanitaires sont en alerte
même si pour le moment aucun cas de
pneumopathies virulente n'a été
constatée en france toutefois deux
personnes sont sous surveillance
la maladie s'est déclarée en asie du sud
est déjà neuf personnes sont mortes et
400 ont été infectées nathalie cause à
l'aéroport de roissy des affiches
mettent en garde les voyageurs qui
rentrent l'asie du sud est
les autorités sanitaires veulent éviter
toute propagation de l'épidémie de
pneumopathie atypique en france cette
maladie d'origine mystérieuse a déjà tué
neuf personnes essentiellement en asie
en france deux cas suspects sont
signalés une femme est actuellement sous
surveillance à l'hôpital de la pitié
salpêtrière
elle revient du vietnam elle a de la
fièvre des difficultés respiratoires
les symptômes de la maladie elle est
hospitalisée effectivement pour que les
examens nécessaires soit fait que ce
soit qu'il y ait un lien ou qu'il n'y en
ait aucun ce qui est aussi parfaitement
possible en février 300 cas suspect sont
d'abord signalé près de hong kong
mais l'épidémie s'étend cent soixante
sept nouveaux cas sont maintenant
signalés dans le monde
alemany slovénie royaume uni suisse ou
encore au canada
la maladie baptisée aussi sar pour
syndrome respiratoire aigu touche
essentiellement hong kong et le vietnam
à l'hôpital français de hanoi une partie
du personnel est contaminée un médecin
de cet hôpital revenu samedi en france a
depuis été placé sous quarantaine on
sait qu'il est très rapidement puisque
j'ai appris le décès de m
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
demandé aux compagnies aériennes de
prendre des précautions
des dizaines de scientifiques cherchent
actuellement à déterminer l'origine
exacte de cette maladie